a palestinian song for the voice of
palestine this church service in london
brought together people from journalism
human rights activism and the arts
united in remembering al jazeera's
shireen abu akhla shot dead in janine by
israeli forces while doing her job
no journalist should ever go through
this in this day and age
shireen's niece lina is one of those
pushing for an independent investigation
into her killing last month she
addressed the service remotely
she
continued to uncover the crimes of
israel when they attacked her funeral at
the french hospital and when they
attacked the palm bearers and were
trying to drop her casket but the people
the people of palestine were resilient
they were steadfast they carried her on
their shoulders the same way she carried
their voices for the past 25 years
she had a rare ability to intervene and
mediate when misunderstandings
arose between her friends
and this is why another friend and i
used to refer to her as our diplomatic
friend
[Music]
singer kalani grew up outside palestine
part of its diaspora
there's people like shireen who are
there who
are there on the front line in jerusalem
in
outside al-aqsa mosque and that helped
me connect we share your pain and your
joy
i was struck really by how many people
were so moved by the story
the horror and tragedy of her killing
her murder
and it shows why really this story is
not going to go away
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the search for justice over shireen's
killing goes on but this was a chance to
celebrate the good that she did to
remember the impact she made in
palestine and beyond
[Music]
nadine barbara al jazeera london